sprechen wir darüber jetzt bei uns im
studium mit dem bundesverkehrsminister
volker wissing von der fdp einen schönen
guten morgen herzlich willkommen guten
morgen alles in allem hat das neue euro
ticket all ihre erwartungen erfüllt ja
das ist ein riesenerfolg wir haben es
geschafft ein digitales ticket sehr
schnell umzusetzen und vor allen dingen
haben wir ein paar dinge verändert
verbund übergreifende geltung des
tickets die die menschen richtig
begeistern in deutschland werden auch
sehr viele umsteiger vom auto auf den
öpnv
drei bis vier mutmaßliche
verkehrsverlagerung das ist enorm und
zeigt wir sind hier wobei deswegen wenn
ich da vielleicht kurz ergänzen darf und
da rein gehen darf es gab natürlich
einen etwas größeren erhofften
ökologischen effekt und der vdv hat
jetzt eben gesagt die tickets wurden
eher für zusätzliche fahrten genutzt als
als ersatz also es gab da eben eine sehr
marginale verschiebung hat man sich dann
nicht mehr gewünscht sagt drei bis vier
prozent verkehrsverlagerungen sind nicht
marginal jetzt müssen wir aber abwarten
was genau am ende die analyse ergibt wir
haben ja eine begleitende studie in
auftrag gegeben die das genau analysiert
und wenn diese fakten vorliegen muss man
die richtigen schlüsse daraus ziehen
klar ist dass wir mit diesem ticket viel
bewegung in den op en v gebracht haben
der pnv ist in aller munde und das war
mein ziel wir haben aber schon seit
meinem amtsantritt
vorstöße unternommen um den öpnv zu
reformieren in deutschland das tag zeit
dem früher eine bund länder
arbeitsgruppe die sich mit
strukturfragen beschäftigt jetzt wollen
sie die beschlüsse oder die erst mal
abwarten was dabei rauskommen bei dieser
untersuchung wann liegen diese fakten
denn dann vor und wann wird entschieden
wie es weitergeht mit dem öpnv und vor
allem wer entscheidet eigentlich sie als
bundesverkehrsminister oder christian
lindner als bundesfinanzminister denn
der hat ein nachfolgemodell ja schön
absage erteilt und der
bundesfinanzminister muss das geld
zusammenhalten das macht ja auch sehr
gut ich muss die gesellschaft mobil
halten und daran arbeite ich wir warten
auch nicht ab sondern wir haben bereits
im frühjahr eine bund länder
arbeitsgruppe eingesetzt ich habe die
länder gebeten eine sonder
verkehrsminister konferenz einzuberufen
damit wir die strukturfragen des öpnv
angehen ich weiß aus früherer
erfahrungen als landesverkehrsminister
das hier reformbedarf besteht
und mit dem neuen euro ticket haben wir
jetzt zusätzlich zu unserer reformarbeit
eine besondere entlastungsmaßnahmen auf
den weg gebracht die bedingt durch den
ukraine krieg notwendig war okay aber
noch mal ganz konkret und kurz eine
verlängerung von 9 euro ticket die gibt
es nicht dieses ticket ist auf drei
monate in dieser form begrenzt das
ergibt sich auch aus dem gesetz das der
bundestag verabschiedet hat das wissen
alle und wussten alle ein solches ticket
ist für 9 euro auch nicht dauerhaft
finanzierbar das würde den bund 13 bis
14 milliarden euro kosten gut und damit
alle möglichkeiten des angebots ausbaus
beschränkten er wissen wenn es keine
günstigeren tickets gibt dann kann eine
alternative
und sie wollen die menschen ja für den
öpnv begeistern ja nur sein das angebot
sonst irgendwie attraktiv zu machen
engere takt um mehr busse mehr züge mehr
personal warum gibt es bislang gar keine
nennenswerten verbesserung das muss
gemacht werden wir brauchen natürlich
wenn wir mehr verlagerung wollen auch
mehr angebot besseres angebot dazu
gehören aber auch fragen etwa dass man
das ticket einfacher nutzen kann wir
haben sehen jetzt dass nur ein euro
ticket begeistert viele weil es sehr
einfach ist wir haben teilweise aber
immer noch auf den bahnsteigen drei
verschiedene fahrkartenautomaten stehen
für unterschiedliche tarifstrukturen das
muss verschwinden wir müssen digitaler
werden einfacher werden auch das gehört
zur verbesserung des angebots und sie
haben recht wir müssen auch die
kapazitäten ausbauen wir haben ja
gesehen dass etwa während der
pfingsttage wir eine sehr starke
auslastung hatten und dann kommen wir an
kapazitätsgrenzen das personal war
extrem belastet menschen dort
großartiges geleistet aber wir sehen es
muss ausgebaut werden und daran arbeiten
kritik gibt es irgend daran das wissen
sie auch dass die fdp jetzt erstmal für
19 euro ticket kein weiteres geld locker
machen will am dienstwagen privileg aber
festhalten will finden sie nicht auch
dass das ein widerspruch ist nun einmal
weil es nichts miteinander zu tun hat
und das ist auch kein dienstwagen
privileg sein das ist eine vereinfachte
form der besteuerung aber
das miteinander zu vermengen macht
keinen sinn dann würde man dass die die
bisherige dienstwagenbesteuerung
verändern würde das nicht zu einem
höheren steueraufkommen führen und wenn
nicht mehr geld da ist kann man auch
nicht mehr geld für den öpnv ausgeben
entscheidend ist dass wir an den
strukturen arbeiten und nicht nur geld
reden wenn man zuerst finanzielle fragen
bespricht und die strukturellen fragen
nach hinten verlagert dann ist man nicht
effizient genug und deswegen war es mir
wichtig dass wir schon im frühjahr diese
bund länder arbeitsgruppe eingesetzt
haben die genau analysieren wird was
können wir strukturell verbessern und
was müssen wir am angebot verbessern
bundesverkehrsminister volker bisschen
von der fdp war das ganz herzlichen dank
für ihren besuch waren zum studio